those little squats get you strong and
the [ __ ] plus they get the dick harder
than debt you wake up in the morning
with that 14 year old dick that's burden
the hole in your pocket and mom is
already cooking breakfast for the kids I
gotta sit there with a hot oven
think about what [ __ ] pure strength
you [ __ ] see what those squats do
D a dick it's nice to wake up in the
heart I love these little half of
fruitcakes I suffer from erectile
dysfunction
come over here 56 with a [ __ ] rocket
to make my pocket that King young whom
we'll look at and go what the [ __ ] has
that missing but the Iranians would have
dropped on a rabs everything with this
[ __ ] I mean it's a dick of death that's
the truth I'm gay I get dirty thoughts
it at night and you think it's because
of like press I think I definitely is I
really believe that squatting I started
squatting after I had knee surgery just
[ __ ] around on my own at the gym I
started doing it at the Y just squatting
because I always knew that if you
squatted first it released something in
your body to make you and I had the knee
surgery and within four months I knocked
my wife up at the age of 49 years old
this is a guy who doesn't to pills or
drink alcohol sleep seven hours a nights
a little overweight and he smokes pot
like a [ __ ] so Harvard said his
smoked reefer your sperm cell go down
when women want to get knocked up they
have to tell their husbands to stop
smoking pot because the sperm cell not
so here's again no tight underwear
either Lee at this time tell them we
were doing $2,000 a night we were eating
2,000 milligrams of stars and chocolates
and that was just I was eating he you
always said I've had eight things today
yeah doing everything we were doing kind
of mean whatever came on the show we
would get down with no delay this is no
blow no heroin no oxys that's it but
every man for himself we're in coding
tablets AJ Benza came on with [ __ ]
pens and holes and [ __ ] felon old he
gave me cat tranquilizers I gave him
crack oh yeah yeah we go deep on this
show but how do you explain somebody
being with somebody for 13 years having
sex with them on us late other regular
level and all of a sudden now yes that
two years off for drugs and I start
squatting again and when I started
squatting I was squatting with 135 five
sets eight but I was working more on my
form than to get hurt because I knew I
was 49 years old and I would do three
sets of eight deadlifts but when I
walked out there I could tell something
was going on and then I started getting
hornier and hornier and hornier and I
knew I put it back to being 16 when I
would hang out with from 16 to 21 I hang
out with bodybuilders and then in
Colorado those bodybuilders became they
came from Brown University
so my buddies new jersey had gone to
brown and that brown they picked up
cleans jerks deadlifts and squats so
there was no more curling allowed they
had a no curling rule in the house if we
see you [ __ ] doing curls you're out
so every day one guy was a garbage man
two guys will construction guys and
myself we would meet downstairs at 6:00
and do this clean whatever program but
we incorporated IRA Wolf's IRA Wolff was
a Jewish guy in our neighborhood that
went to the Olympics as an assistant
strength and conditioning coach in 84
and his principles were the power of 10
in 1984 when you worked out with him
yeah before football he thought before
basketball if he didn't play football
you had a do cross-country with him it
really wasn't cross-country running it
was a little bit of sprinting and a lot
of heavy weight low reps slow bench
squats he would call them I still
remember his bench squat and I sternum
my vertical jump going from 28 inches to
now I could grab the [ __ ] rim and in
freshman year my freshman year I was
jumping up and grabbing the rim I
couldn't slam dunk
and I always accredited that to his
training his training was not two hours
guys his training was very quick
Bing Bing bench squats overhead press
something else pull-ups and I couldn't
do pull-ups so he would put the bench
under for me and just make me hold at a
certain time little egg gold I
remembered all that [ __ ] and you know
you would walk out of there not
exhausted but you thought every vein and
your body was about to pop and then he'd
make you do cross country but 345 60s
and then a 100-yard dash and you went
home let's see you Wednesday so when I
read about all this you knew it made
sense I thought we were on reading some
podcast ville it's Monday the 23rd of
September you better get your [ __ ]
together [ __ ] the podcast is
brought to you by CBD lion calm listen
when it comes to CBD everybody's got the
[ __ ] answer Faber who takes care like
uncle Joey
nobody CBD de Lyon is the way to go go
to CBD line.com right now and look at
that third-party test results listen
they make that product from start to
finish this is no voodoo store or some
[ __ ] gasoline station you can't be
that [ __ ] stupid uncle Joey's here to
tell you
CBB line.com also the church is brought
to you by listen hiring can be a slow
process guys you know it's a thousand
things that could go wrong zip recruiter
is the way to go they've put a a
60-second video live type thing it's
Gillen Moskowitz is a real zip recruiter
customer there's a real testimony I want
you to go over and take a look at this
difficult ISM play
they've got technology that identifies
you with the right people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job so you get the qualified
candidates quickly all right so with
results like that it's no wonder four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day it's that easy
zip CY zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes whether you got
two guys selling hot dogs or three
hundred people making shirts zip
recruiter is the website for you then
now but right now when Joey's gonna give
it to you for free you like joy what are
you talking about Freight I'm telling
you it's free I'm gonna give you a shot
just go to zip recruiter comm slash
shirts at CU h you rc8 said zip
recruiter dot-com slash shirts listen
zip recruit is the smallest way to ha
I'm here to save you time and
aggravation but besides time and
aggravation and getting y'all hooked up
with CD I'm gonna give you an
opportunity to make a little dough Raimi
and then you're like Joey with me you
gonna teach me how to sing [ __ ] no I'm
gonna teach you how to how to make some
paper cuz the church it's also brought
to you by my book you listening if you
found a hundred miles on the street
would you pick it up would you keep
walking after you dummies will keep
walking down line one one [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you put that money in your pocket you
gonna buy a half a grandma blow and you
tell your girlfriend the polish that
[ __ ] you're coming over
of course you take the money so why do
you keep picking when it's not betting
them that's why you got to deal with my
bookie
it's fast it's easy and they pay when
you win let's face it where your bet is
just
is important as who you betting on if
you're trying to bet on the NFL baseball
and we're going into playoff baseball
now [ __ ] MMA whatever my bookies got
it I'm I wouldn't be telling you guys to
bet with them if they weren't the best
do the smart thing if you're gonna bet
this football season bet with my bookie
did you know that you can bet on games
after kickoff you like Joey what are you
talking about yeah by the second half if
it looks like we put the bet in for you
though you can always just take the
other side if you're that kind of guy
that likes to bet a little win a lot try
a parlay this is the way to go
double your first deposit now use promo
code Church to get 100% bonus on your
initial deposit of $1,000 visit my
bookie dot AG today that's my booking
dot AG and don't forget to use promo
code Church CH you are CH when creating
your account you play you win you get
paid don't forget Thursday I'll be on
Instagram with uncle Joey's my bookie
day is Thursday so go over there right
now and check out because it's [ __ ]
you should be ashamed of yourself
that you're missing out on money check
this [ __ ] melee oh [ __ ] it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
it's gonna be a great weekend at the
world by the balls don't worry about
nothing that could be worse you could be
Antonio Brown boy [ __ ] all you know I'm
saying for Antonio sitting there the
phone's gonna ring no one ain't [ __ ]
the cops are gonna come with Hank that's
all that's coming on the show today
tremendous friend guest trainer
entrepreneur the whole [ __ ] pioneer
Anju's zickerman right Adam Adams
Dickerman Andrew what the [ __ ] I'm
nervous
the original price killers with me at
least I add after a long weekend
he's got stories from San Diego some
girl got into the car and one of the
sexually abused them and he went the
other way and down 9-1-1 as usual he was
married [ __ ] it was only having eight
stories like this I don't know what it
is about me
cracks the crates up she wanted to kill
her ex-boyfriends chickens it was the
weirdest now my life sure wasn't the
whole time nothing you didn't have to
ask she was married you call all bets
are off
I'm saying this a you like a lyft driver
Adam what's happening doing man thanks
what brings you that way absolutely I
had a great time training at your gym
while I was there to shoot the soprano
film and it was fun a great experience
you know the whole thing that you do is
still so far hidden from the world
and it's I tapped on to the power 10
like I just said to you in 1980 had to
be 1979 with this cat named IRA Wolfe
and it was basically a way of working
out that you know all your other coaches
were making rerun hills and you know you
went home that night and every bone in
your body ache you know Lee and I were
part of a kettle bell class you know you
look back at it now he has swinging 80
pound kettlebells in this weird
positions and you if you went to the
class on Tuesday you couldn't walk to a
[ __ ] Friday I mean not walk and you
have to ask yourself how is this
beneficent fitting my body this for the
last couple years since I had the baby
my desire is to live to live a healthier
type of lifestyle the best that I can
you know I'm not gonna tell you I'm
likely the pastrami sandwich well I'm in
New York but I won't eat the fries I'll
have a salad with it so we'll go half
way but one of the things as I was
trying to find a system that would work
for a man over 50 I started reading
about it I you know I really loved you
Jitsu but that was a four three day of
recovery and then every time he went
your shoulder hurt somebody got you a
shoulder lock something I am
and then I wanted to kick the caloric
burn up so I went with Muay Thai and
jiu-jitsu Muay Thai and how we're movie
time you can burn up to a thousand
calories that's a fat burner plus it
will help a fifty-year-old breathe a
little better whatever but I felt there
was something missing after that three
or four year experiment I really thought
there was something missing from my life
and unlike other people I always enjoyed
weight lifts since the age of 15 I
always enjoyed five sets of six straight
bar just the main body parts no [ __ ]
around
that's a house benchpress
in Cline's bent over row pull over
curl tricep extension squat and you're
out of there so unique that was the but
that was the eighties the 80s you ibly
want to be Mike Mike Metzger in the
eighties everybody was still every Mike
Bettes there was a guy that devised of
Mike Mike mentor mentor and the angular
correct me a lot there's no problem that
battery acid the Guns and Roses lesson
Mike münster how to work out that he did
what was it 20 sets per body part so if
you did your chest you had to do five
bench presses five inclines five
dumbbells and then a set of flies five
times you think about that that's a lot
of [ __ ] work five days a week and you
had a cover there was either push and
pull method or there was just a straight
up you know three days a week of squats
and I had friends that made you know we
were big in that North Bergen New Jersey
sterling my buddy making Puerto Rican
squat machines with the wire and they
would get their uncle to weld the piece
and they would put two 35 pound plates
with a with a wire string and they were
got a broomstick and we will pull it
down at the house and you know I mean
this was everybody had their own
homemade that's really cool maxilla
everybody everybody and everybody had
different techniques but there was just
one kid ferny that disappeared for a
summer he's Cuban he ate steak and black
beans and rice every day for a summer
and he stuck to a regimen of five sets
of six which including behind-the-neck
presses and we were all gung-ho on it so
the whole neighborhood wanted to get big
some of us did win Stroh and win Eevee
some of us didn't because I don't like
needles so it was always something that
I really enjoyed so when I was looking
for that gap and what was going out my
life I'm gonna burn more calories I ran
across your book one night online and I
read it was excerpts of your book on
what your message I'm gonna ask you ask
you how you found yeah no that's how I I
found excerpts of your book and then I
found your gym hmm and sure enough as
I'm gonna fly to New York twice a week
to train with the man who wrote this
book so for the last five years I've
been going to this place to eat the
green apple because they have the best
hemily chicken no points on weight
watches it's having chicken and like a
light sauce with no sugar and white rice
and I'll go up there and it's basically
it's six points for the rice and right
after I shot my Netflix special and I
thought my life was a mess I went I
there was no parking on the street so I
parked in the back and as I walked out I
looked and there was this small boutique
very what you'd say my world
la type of gym like I had to go in there
and talk about you know my service dog
you know cuz it's next to a yoga joint
and I've sat there many of hours
eating Chinese food my wife or ally or
friends or agents and I have sat there
and watched these [ __ ] yoga people
you know walk out with that teeth tears
the chia seeds on the way out and faking
the funk and you look at this gym and
they had a pamphlet and I took the
pamphlet and read it and I took it home
and I go
Jesus God works in mysterious ways
and I called them up and I went for an
initial consultation and I gotta be
honest for the first three weeks I
thought it was kind of [ __ ]
I'm like I got taken that's what I get
for being a [ __ ] [ __ ] and there's
a CrossFit gym by my house I could go on
any Groupon and right now in Studio City
there's a thousand string shins I don't
let you go and then do whatever the [ __ ]
you want and there was an interesting
strength-based school and burbank that
they made you strength left and then do
Jiu Jitsu I liked it but I'm 56
well the funk at that time but I got it
I got a Duke Earl I gotta do squats and
go on the mat and show how the squats
working my jujitsu so that's how I found
Joe Adam was through the book little
excerpts mm-hmm they spoke a lot about
ken Hutchison did the studies in 82 Ken
Hutchins with the older people but uh it
also helped I'm gonna say he's a dick so
they said to reach out to you no no no
I'm just teasing he's eccentric he's
very happy
he has his enemies and they just said
that you you know you have new articles
and vanity and all these magazines
I just became very interested in your
science now you got involved this yeah
well I I give myself credit not for
pioneering this because it was Ken
Hutchins and it was Arthur Jones who
Nautilus founder and the Mike mentors
Mike mentor was very close with Arthur
Jones tell these [ __ ] about tom
platt
can you make my thighs look like now
yeah well you know no I don't think so
you know you know it's it's hard to know
I mean genetics is is a big factor in
all of this and we don't know if you've
ever achieved your genetic potential and
how you did it you know so it's possible
to make your legs like his I know I
can't make my legs like this my skinny
ass Jewish legs you know there's no way
but uh you know going back to how I my
involvement in this technique was just
hearing these guys these obscure voices
that nobody wanted to listen to because
conventional exercise and marketing was
taking over cardio and Jane Fonda and
all that stuff so it's hard to break
through those voices and less was more
you know in these ideas so I was like
this is something because I was like you
and you talking about all the stuff you
did and how you got hurt I that's what
happened to me you know I got very hurt
doing all the crazy stuff I was working
in a lab you know I was I was a
scientist early yet you know I graduated
with a degree in science and I thought
it's gonna be in research my whole life
and I'm in the lab I'm a little man on a
told pole you know there's all these
really smart researcher biochemists
there and I just get I'm just out of
school and I'm washing test tubes and
stuff and but I am the only jock there
I'm the only guy there that cares about
exercise you got all these science nerds
you know and so here I am proselytizing
about exercise showing off telling them
you'll have to exercise you'll have to
exercise and my boss a genius guy says
some you know Adam I hear you talking
about exercise a lot you know that we
should all do this we should all do that
and we watch you and you're working out
every day and you're doing this and
doing that I got to say you look like
[ __ ] I'm like whoa and that really took
me aback and he went on to explain what
he meant he says listen you look good
you you know you're 19 years old how bad
can someone look in nineteen years old
but you know you always hurt you're sick
all the time you're at your your nursing
injuries you know you've already had
back surgery from from an exercise
injury if that's what exercise is about
you know count me out and it wasn't
until many years later that it came
across Ken Hutchins and Arthur Jones
when I realized that and this is a big
big moment in my life because I always
had what my boss said in the back of my
mind but it never really clicked until I
was reading Ken Hutchins and I realized
that what good is exercise and what good
is getting fit if it's gonna undermine
your health you know my dad is a perfect
example of somebody that was fit his
whole life and now he's at double bypass
surgery he can't walk he's a walker his
quality of life sucks ironically because
of how he exercised he beat himself into
the ground with orthopedic problems and
well let's talk about cardio and running
marathons meanwhile he's had triple
bypass surgery you know I was like
questioning all these like a scientist
says you know if there's an exception to
the rule the rule is wrong you know that
that's Richard Feynman that the Nobel
prize-winning physicist who said that
from Caltech he you know with all this
cardio going on how come orthopedic
surgeons are are booming
obesity is higher than ever if it's
supposed to burn all these calories you
know I I was like there's got to be
something to this this this is not the
answer we don't know everything there is
to know about exercise you know we have
like the zeitgeist in our society now
you know that that there's two types of
exercise you know cardio and
strength-training
you know that's changed it's not true
that it's you know it's not separate
anymore you know it's workout hard like
you were talking about like that that
Jewish guy who taught my IRA wolf I
think he said is yes you know he knew he
had this intuition that was back in 82
say lift away slowly less is more you do
the basic exercise you do the full body
full form he focused on full form he had
that intuition and the breathing which
at 19 16 and 17 you're looking at
somebody gonna [ __ ] you I don't need my
breathing everything's amazing
that's amazing he's actually talking
about words on breathing before you put
a bar on your neck or got into a rack he
would make you do the movement of the
squat to the breathing but you went away
from it you didn't think wrong blacks
being wrong you know if you hear all
that you're not doing something and you
didn't realize it you know I didn't
realize didn't realize it till seven
years later when I was swimming I went
to Boulder and joined the Masters
swimming program if you swim like a
gorilla see how long you'll last if you
relax your body like water like Bruce
Lee said and just let that rest take you
and also you're going to do more miles
because you're not tan so we swim we
feel like we got a launch splashing and
look at the guy next to you he's not
even [ __ ] making noise but he's not
burning any energy and that was that
that was like rule numbers whatever in
your book don't hold your breath
yes breathe as you know breathing don't
hold your price free relaxed blood
pressure goes up your performance goes
down you trying to get the most out of
your muscles and you're depriving them
of oxygen stupid come back to what way
you came up with this whole hang well
like I said I didn't come up with it so
like Here I am I'm like remember have
that my boss's voice in the back of my
head and then Ken Hutchins starts
talking then I read cannot and he's like
you got to breathe less is more you know
we're killing ourselves you know you
know you don't have to lock out your
joints you don't you know one set that
failure you know I was like oh my god I
mean all of a sudden the voice of my
boss back in the laboratory just came to
me I'm like he was right the whole time
he was right and then it took me to hear
it a second time from ken hutchinson
later many injuries later you know to
realize oh my god you know we're we're
approaching this all wrong you know it's
about this much muscle failure not how
you got to muscle
it's about getting the muscle failure
and not [ __ ] yourself up in the
process and like you said you're 50
years old what you gonna do now jujitsu
yeah you can get in great damn shape
doing jujitsu but you can also get
seriously hurt doing jujitsu and then
you're out for six months so it's the
Lord that my cell phone returns
I see the drop kid over that I had
bursitis he didn't know what was going
on as me you got a staph infection is
[ __ ] me yeah a surgery [ __ ] that's
serious stuff that's serious stuff this
is something that so I'm looking to get
off number I just don't sit at home with
ice pack I lose my wife doesn't eat
we don't eat I gotta go on the road we
could eat so I can't do anything then I
gotta walk around you know there's six
hour flights it's bad enough for you
back like I tell people all the time
it's not the lifting weights I hurts my
back it's the three hours in the
computer trying to try a type of [ __ ]
act so sitting sitting is the worst
thing for you in the [ __ ] world and
you gonna laugh at me but maybe you
should get a standing desk I'm not I'm
Way ahead of that that's the next move I
just thought we measured that that's the
other day I have a big computer screen
so we're gonna have to get a block well
you can do those deaths where they
elevate and then go down like right for
the walk when you're sick of that just
sit down for a while I went to my
friend's offices saw the death bet and
he looks great by doing it what did you
consider writing the book about your
findings so when I read Ken Hutchins and
I had my boss on my head I was like okay
that's it game changer I'm changed my
life I realized I wasn't gonna all the
researchers were making like ten
thousand dollars a year and I was look I
was you know I was not gonna make money
in research for a long time and money
was you know part of my motivation for
career anyway I was like I think there's
gonna lot of people out there that would
exercise if they knew that they're not
going to kill themselves attempting to
do it I said this needs to be known
about this idea of working out slowly
and safely and get really strong without
putting us
in harm's way that's a big message that
is a paradigm shift actually they hate
they hate that expression paradigm shift
but this truly was in my mind and I said
I'm doing I'm going for it I'm gonna
take this information that that no one
knows about and see if I can popularize
it and so I started just training people
in the basement I started my business
part-time you know in the basement of
some smelly building chain-smoker used
to be in the space before me and so my
first gym actually smells like cigarette
smoke but it was free and I was actually
able to train clients and practice what
I was and then went around I went down
spent time with Ken Hutchins I had all
these mentors and I just learned as much
as I could and I just went for it next
thing you know it one of my clients
writes a letter to the local news
station on Channel 12 News I'm very a
local station and it says this changed
my life it's less is more and I've tried
everything out I used to beat myself in
the ground but now with diet and and
just working I once a week really hard
but safely it's changed my body so they
sent the news crew to my little hole in
a wall basement and I was like wow that
was pretty easy so I started writing
letters to all the editors of all the
major magazines everywhere I just sent
out 15 this is back in 97 I'm 30 years
old now it's back in 97 there's no
internet to speak up I can't just look
in Google who's the editor chief of this
place in that place and send an email
all right I was writing actual letters
and I was buying all the magazines from
the bodega to find out who these people
were I'd send out snail mail letters
that probably 50 to 70 media sources
just saying I have this technique of
working out once a week 20 minutes I
never would have press release in my
life but I figured how hard can it be
next thing you know it nobody calls me
except for one publication in New York
Times I mean I sent out like I said
between set 50 to 75 letters and only
one publication poem in New York Times
they sent a reporter and photographer
down to my hole in a wall in Massapequa
Long Highlands
took a picture of me training somebody
and boom I get calls from publishers
everybody wants to know what's this
about I get a million calls in Manhattan
I don't have a place in Manhattan
everyone wants to work out me
and doesn't seem like anymore on Long
Island reads The Times because no I
think I didn't get where I was so I'm
telling all these people that are
calling me from New York I'll be opening
I have a place I'm I'll be open in six
months give me your name and number I'll
be open in six months
I lied I didn't have a place but I found
I started looking for I forgot a broker
I got placement and I literally was open
I think in eight months I called all
those people back 90% you know who the
hell I was so 10% did and 10% came in
and my pistons on Long Island is doing
very well despite the fact that nobody
read the New York Times article but I
was still doing really well there
because people were talking it was all
word of mouth anyway and believe it or
not my long I'll occasion supported the
rent in midtown Manhattan a small little
room in midtown Manhattan when you were
there Joey it's much bigger I expand my
favorite lifts day one I've been there
since day since year two I had my
business on Manhattan on Massapequa in
97 I opened up the Manhattan location in
because that New York Times article I
opened up the New York location in 99 in
a small room and then and then the
tuxedo plays went out of business next
to me and that's when my book came out
and was perfect timing because that's
when the flood of business came in and
then I became its media during my 15
minutes of fame for a while when the
book came out and you know the rest is
history but what it was the New York
Times article that led to the book deal
so I didn't seek out a book deals matter
of fact that's funny I was pretty
pretentious at this time full of piss
and vinegar and I thought my way he was
the only and the only way you can do
this work out is if you have a trainer
so when they said let's do a book deal
Magna Adam or I'd do a book deal because
you can't do this on your own you know
and they talked me into it because they
said well as the principles the
principles of lifting weights slowly the
principles of working out hard and not
killing yourself that that's universal
that's that's a principle that you can
teach anyone and you can do this with
dumbbells really if you think about it
can't you I'm like well that's true so
they had to kind of twist my arm a
little bit Believe It or Not to get a
book deal which is kind of weird that's
how full of myself I was to be honest
with you but anyway I did
and I got a lot more pressed on that
point than media people were working out
with us in Manhattan and so what do I
get credit for I think I get credit for
popularizing it to bring it to the
forefront as far as the development of
this pioneering is now that that credit
goes to Kant Hutchins off the Jones and
some people before them now when I go a
little MCA they have free weights and
they have machines the machines that you
your facilities offer are they hand
crafted for specific exercises like we
spoke about yourself but yeah I really
enjoyed your squat machine it wasn't
like I was using my back yeah I was
basically even if it was mediocre weight
because Jonathan was taking a little
light on me after three minutes
jesus [ __ ] christ but I think you
learned pretty quickly that the pretty
strong [ __ ] it's weird how are
those machines specifically made for
your style of training yeah a lot of
them are I mean that's why is that what
Kachins game is exactly exactly so Ken
Hutchins said by the way we're doing all
these things by mechanically incorrect
all right he says you know their
biomechanics here people I mean muscles
have strength curves they have weak
points and they and they have strong
points and you shouldn't be
over taxing a muscle at its weak point
and free weights and conventional
machines do exactly that and again we're
trying to avoid joint proms and a lot of
times the reason we get hurt during
exercise is because the weights too
heavy when the joint is at its weakest
position so these machines that Ken
Hutchins thought about and Arthur Jones
actually thought about even before him
is that you have to vary the resistance
through the range of motion to match the
weaknesses and strengths of that muscle
group so before that you know the weight
was way too heavy through a range of
motion so now Ken Hutchins says you know
what we're gonna make it lighter here
we're gonna make it heavier here and
match the strength curve of that muscle
and make it much more friendlier for the
joint especially when you're lifting
weights slowly when you lift weight
slowly it really magnifies those
differences in the strength curves so so
without getting too technical
bottom line is Ken Hutchins redesigned
the original Nautilus machines that
Arthur Jones came up with and made it
much more smooth and safer for the
joints as you went through the range of
motion so yes if if you specialize in
this type of technique of training the
slow lifting to failure there are
machines out there that that are more
accommodating for that if you work if
you're lucky to work at a place like
that you know that's great it's like the
rolls-royce of this type of workout but
like my team at the publisher said the
principles are still the same right I
mean there are ways of getting around
that if you know what you're doing and
that's what my book did is that I knew
no one was gonna have access around the
country in the world the book ended up
being at best so so you know there's a
lot of copies of that book out there all
over the place and um you know I came up
with routines I had nothing to do with
my equipment because I knew people were
going to really have access to my
equipment so I showed them how you can
do it with regular stuff there are some
things she's just a void you know you
don't want to do a lateral raise
straight up like that I really hurts the
shoulder and that's not one of the most
popular so I was around and people are
doing this all day wrong you got
trainers killing people's shoulders
without even knowing it you know so we
show you how to do that without hurting
your shoulders even with a free weight
so there little tricks you know and so
you can just honestly it's not rocket
sunny just want to avoid hurting
yourself like I said the beginning of
the show you don't you want to get fit
but not undermine your health and and
part of that health is joint health I
mean half the prom I mean you know god
forbid cancer is a big one right but
like after cancer and some of the big
ones that really kill you the next one
is like living and paying your whole
life with hip prom then back prom the
solar proms who wants to live like that
I mean a lot of people a lot of pain and
again ironically it's because they were
told how to workout a certain way doing
jujitsu in the name of exercise now
jiu-jitsu is great one of the big things
that ken Hutchins love to talk about was
a distinction between exercise and
recreation and what people do is they
end up thinking they're doing something
recreational like jiu-jitsu or something
really challenging basketball wrestling
right these are sports sports were not
meant to get you in shape sports or
sports it's competition right that's fun
it's challenging a lot of benefits to
playing sport
but it's not technically good exercise
if your definition of exercise is to get
strong and not take any risk and that's
my definition of exercise that was Ken
Hutchins definition of exercise says
exercise to get strong and don't put
yourself in any risk play sports because
you like sports and you like all the
other things that come from sport but
don't confuse the two don't confuse your
exercise with sports and vice versa
so when you're talking about the
clean-and-jerk so you were doing and all
those Olympic lifts are you doing
Olympic lifts our sport lifts that's a
technique you know for exercise it's a
poor choice of exercise because you're
gonna hurt yourself doing those on the
pick lifts that's a that's a tough soft
that's why CrossFit is kind of like more
of a sport then to me then really safe
exercise I look at what's going on to
the hair look at football I look at how
they shine children away from football
now I came from a town where day and
carries football in the first grade all
my friends that come to my shows now
have known each other from peewee
football and then you go on to read our
Eagle football and read greater football
and what my hometown does is they teach
you those plays so when you become a
freshman you already have the
fundamentals of that play but a long
came called the Bruin mentality North
Bergen is the second pileus town in the
country behind San Francisco so every
coach you had was Hill crazy
I still remember freshman year this
[ __ ] scumbag of a man Dan riddle who
if we lost would make this run up and
down a certain hell with our hands up
you know it was barbaric ways of lifting
we there were kids that were lifting to
get strong and to benefit and then it
was the early eighties where it was an
epidemic of syringes so half of us how
to make a decision of who did what but
no matter where you went in my hometown
the workouts
were brutal you know we'd pile on 300
pounds there was no science we kindly
use the Irish science but today I can't
shoot a basketball today there's a
thousand things I can't do because I
storm him but putting 185 and doing
behind the next five sets of six and
hearing things poppin but who you you
weren't allowed to complain long from
there was no pain I remember a time we
would make milkshakes with gallons of
ice cream and 12 eggs because the
barbarian brothers remember the
barbarian brothers oh no [ __ ] steroid
twins from the eighties that just said
that they didn't do steroids they just
ate 36 hours a day so hey everybody in
America you'd see people eat and [ __ ]
everybody's everybody smelt like [ __ ]
farts and everybody was eating raw eggs
all day one of those hard-boiled eggs
well because of our barbarian brothers
but what we did looking back on it was
destroying our bodies not looking at it
now it's 2019 and Lee lives in my
neighborhood and will attest to this and
we could take a ride after this and
you'll see it if once you hit Riverside
or Magnolia once you start going on
those after Magnolia you guys are gonna
start start seeing a bunch of cross
fitness gym with the main one being one
on then Tora Boulevard then as you're
driving you see these [ __ ] morons I'm
not even doing the farmer walks hmm
they're doing the one-armed farmer walks
and you know I'm watching you know I go
online and I see what they're doing and
it is amazing I love kettlebells don't
let me tell you something somewhere
along the line you're gonna get hurt
with kettlebells because if you see
their basic swing hmm look at the arch
of your spine exactly you know that it
doesn't take a [ __ ] genius and I'm
genealogists I didn't take PE and
[ __ ] University of Colorado I'm just
telling you by looking and how I felt
thank you when I was doing those things
Pavlov whether the fluff his name what's
his name that have Hobbes don't know
what's the [ __ ] guy that did the the
kettle bell the hardstyle cannibals it's
Russian or the Russian guy yeah a
Russian yeah
he made one a great point if you read
what he read he read kettle bells are
designed not to burn you out but to make
you feel like you did something in other
words he has it like this [ __ ] of ten
sets of ten swings in ten minutes
and then 16 sets of Queens that wasn't
his intention that's with us as greedy
Americans being number one
added to it whatever his name wanted you
to do three set to twelve maybe three
sets of ten cleans and maybe four takers
get-ups and that was it it wasn't meant
to destroy you
it was meant to bring your muscles to be
alive and a jaded blood in your muscles
and that was it but I think somewhere as
us as Americans we've abused this and in
the next 20 years the injuries will
CrossFit are gonna be these people these
kids are not gonna be able to wipe their
asses we're going backwards we're going
back and that's what made me when I read
your page your book I read the pure
strength pamphlet I said Wow
we're onto something yeah that's you
know that's you working a it's pure
strength I mean like you said it's a
small little place I mean you mean wall
is CrossFit all over the place I mean I
mean it drives me crazy I will get in
the car with you and you go Joey no no
it isn't I will show you just on Colfax
there's two in the same Center so while
you're waiting for the left to change on
Ventura mmm you'll see them running
upstairs
bama's walks and they go back and forth
once you hook that left no exaggeration
30 yards it's called something like that
the channel bell kingdom two floors I
mean listen you got do a lot of swinging
to keep those lights on that better be a
lot of [ __ ] swinging we ever
see how narcos Mexico I know the show I
have you seen our close Mexico so first
the episode of Millar close Mexico
the guy was saving the farm and he lost
his eye so at the first meeting with the
gangsters he goes what did you guys do
you guys just let them take the weed
from you the guy raises angio's senior
and lost an eye yeah well I see a lot of
[ __ ] here with two eyes you
know you could it's it's it's amazing
what and you'll be driving on Ventura
and when it gets to be 99 on those days
because now a it's 89 at much time it's
bearable it's 3:30
wait so it's like you get in your car
this is one away Christ and then you
drive a little bit in it's 99 or 100
Drive on Ventura 330 and see what you
see when you make that left
you're gonna go wait until a lawsuit
start coming in you know they gotta
walking up and down stairs running down
Ventura foreigner walks doing this [ __ ]
while they're running with [ __ ]
kettlebells you know it is and you look
at it now as a 56 year old I'm like then
I get nowhere they're killing themselves
to live yeah but if I tell them if I
tell somebody that believes in that oh
yeah you have an argument people gonna
send me this stuff well so Joey
like what what about Adam appeal to you
because like as someone who has every
every workout class and every gym always
held will we were the word change in the
game and this is different
and and ever everyone has like that like
claim and some of them suck and some of
them are great but what about his I
think deal you for helping people I
don't believe in Yelp Yelp to suck my
dick lady comes in and works out with
Jonathan she really wants to suck his
dick so Jonathan is great but then I go
see general he sucks ass I don't want it
I took the style of working out and I
just googled it and googled that WebMD
dit and the results were results I
wanted it took away the beginnings of
diabetes too because of the weight
training and the rise of insulin it
plays into that game you also lost our
weight it played in the game of lowering
your blood pressure what's the first
thing they tell you not god forbid
anybody in this room what's the first
thing they tell you when your grandpa
gets a heart attack
he made it because he was strong what
they just tell you they didn't tell you
he made it because he could run from
here the month as soon as we get to
French you know thank God he made those
runs every day they really saved his
life they always say that to you
he made it because he was strong I know
him taking out the garbage would do it
all those days whenever the [ __ ]
strength is big yeah you know but I
think to help you answer the question is
that it's down to its basic common
denominator it's it's stripped down this
exercise stripped down to what you're
supposed to do it the purpose of and
that rings true to a lot of people and
you say exercise is just about getting
strong like you just said it's not about
being able to run to Martha's room it's
being strong that's what saves your life
and it's for me the message is very
clear let's forget all this bells and
whistles stuff and kettlebells and
different techniques and killing
yourself and working out really hard
yes working out hard as important you
got to push yourself but why push
yourself to get hurt that's a very
simple question that can be easily fixed
just work out hard yes work out hard but
just doing
Safeway so you don't pay the price later
that's all we're saying that's all ken
hutchinson and that rang true with me
because I I'm I'm licking my wounds and
Joey you're looking your wounds and
you've been there done that and then you
have re and your Vil in your head he's
like hey with my ADD one coach ty told
me not to do it because the intuition
has been that and wait before I or in
1980 I think you said it was around
there was this Bob Hoffman a bodybuilder
called Bob Hoffman wrote an article
don't quote me on this but I think was
by 1962 1962 Bob Hoffman wrote an
article and in one of the strength
magazine it's talking about lifting
weights slowly you know again the
intuition has been there about lifting
weight slowly enslave safely to to
really fatigue a muscle it's this is not
hard stuff to get around then yes so
well if just fatiguing the muscle what
is what it's all about then why are we
doing all those other things why are we
doing 3 sets of 10 and 15 different ways
that are going to compromise the joints
when it's not necessary when people are
getting just as strong working out once
a week for 20 minutes I mean the proof
is in the pudding you can work out three
days a week four days a week versus once
a week the way we prescribe and people
aren't getting 4 times stronger than our
clients I mean if you're gonna work out
4 times as long you better have four
times the results but not even close you
know maybe maybe one and a half times
results but but at what risk so you know
I kind of feel that our workout is not
so much about this great scientific
discovery because we've all known you
have to work out hard what I think is
great about this workout it's about risk
management that's what we're finally
taking into account nobody takes into
account the risk associated with a
stimulus like exercise a very powerful
stimulus exercises and they can do as
much harm as it can do good and when you
know if you respect exercise for the
fact that it can do harm and it can do
good when you start to respect it and
say how do we get the most out of it
without hurting ourselves this is
because why it becomes it becomes
lifting weight slowly once or twice a
week and I don't know everything else
kind of pales in comparison
until something even more efficient or
safe even comes along so I'm open for
more suggestions it's crazy and those
are the first three of
weeks I was like this is [ __ ]
I just got duped and then something
started to have to happen I would walk
out of that I feel like a [ __ ] boss
it the walk to the car where's my [ __ ]
was moving how nervous they get being at
a light when they have my Subaru and my
form just started quivering and I was
like and then I won another month I
signed up for another month what the
[ __ ] and that month you know now I
couldn't go to box on Tuesday mornings
she's crashed I can't [ __ ] and got the
bit you don't do something Wednesday cuz
it attacks you even more like what did
they [ __ ] do I didn't these things
with my legs then I did 20 minutes push
them in and I pulled down on something
and I turned on something and I can't
[ __ ] move I gotta go to the Chinese
lady and happy hands over here the best
massage twenty bucks
I took lino [ __ ] nothing like that
legit legit legit they soak your feet
nicest people I got a punch card and
everything they're tremendous everyone
after ten that's why you brought me
together I took them because I wanted
him to experience it's a nice little
afternoon thing but all jokes aside it
was rough I couldn't it was either going
as I started right I did it for one time
for two months one time a week for two
months and then I said I gotta jump on
this but I tell you what made me a
believer afterward the breathing I like
to breathe in and I liked it when you
know when you go to a gym I gotta hear
[ __ ] back rap music or [ __ ] rig a
tone you know I don't what other ten
gyms really has on what you want you
guys didn't have that you guys have
yourself to listen to and that's really
different when there's no bells
there's no whistles
and you're really listening to your body
that also came from ken hutchinson way
that is the most brilliant part of that
workout I incorporate that workout
Mondays and Thursdays I want my Monday
is to start in my head while I'm working
out we really don't have to one night
when you and I work on our job we talked
but we kept it you know and the other
thing is that it's what America is
praising today if we talk to every
exercise specialist they're talking to
you about it about doing three minutes
rest in 30 seconds you know the first
couple times you do the squat at your
place
same thing need a couple [ __ ] minute
rest but the more consistent I get now
I'm turning this into a hit program I'm
going from there to the benching to the
banging to the pulling to the [ __ ] V
things to the back machine and it now
you're turning into this and you know
what it's funny like I think I looked at
one of your web pages isn't one of your
videos on YouTube and this is joke that
guys like why is he working out with his
suit [ __ ] cuz you don't even break a
sweat you dumb [ __ ] you just
know that you've been hit people I apply
on me we literally have these
businessmen in Manhattan coming in they
loosen their tie they take their sports
jacket off and they work out just like
that and you know people make fun of us
for that like it must be some kind of
[ __ ] work out of something like that
and we laugh back in their face like you
just said you know yeah we're actually
working out we're only having to break a
sweat but we're getting just as strong
as you are [ __ ] you walk out of
there and right now I'm walking around
around 294 when I joined the program it
was about 292 I'm sure you know they do
a BMI test over and strengthen that she
I have put on muscle I was fat you know
and he listen I'm over 50
I got a child I got a thousand things on
my plate
wish I could go to Georgia two or three
hours a week I wish a checkbox for two
hours a week
56 recovery is a lot and this is where
this exercise this exercise this program
also stresses two things that America
loves and that's rest and recovery we
allow I signed up if I move to New York
tomorrow and I come see and I had a
million dollars less idea coach I'm
ready
you'd say Joey I love to take your
[ __ ] money but for you to see the
results I thought I see you Monday and
maybe Thursday and I'll switch up the
results me and then we'll see where you
go from there
I'd love to take your money I love
people who say I'm gonna go see Josh
John five days this week they're taking
you know the company you'll come in a
wheelchair but front for them my
Thursday you're like today I could just
do the pulldown up to here no you can't
do this you know you can't you why is
the recovery from this type of exercise
so important why do you stress well it's
intense I mean your your what does it do
to your muscle that bodybuilding doesn't
do for example like if I was a
bodybuilder
bodybuilders go push Monday pull Tuesday
Wednesday or push Monday pull Tuesday
Friday and Saturday off Sunday the
steroids kick in you know now I'm sure
you come back you look in the mirror
you're like I'm bigger than ever because
then it lifts the last 2-way phase and
you just realized I recovered there's a
couple of things going on bodybuilders
first of all people body builds
gravitate to bodybuilding because they
have a natural inclination to to get big
they see it you know so they gravitate
towards it we all gravitate the things
that we're good at so early on
bodybuilders usually find that they're
good at weightlifting something draws
them to it secondly they have the body
type that happens to do well under a lot
of exercise there are genotypes there
are genetic profiles of people and
there's lots of different genetic
markers that and if you have the Royal
Flush of genetic marker
you you could work out almost every day
and get bigger and bigger and bigger and
then of course like you said the
steroids involved which improves
recovery ability your natural recovery
ability you can even work out more and
get bigger but the thing is if you don't
have that genetics doesn't matter what
you do you're not gonna get big like
those guys and for most of us because
that genotype the bodybuilder genotype
is rare it's very rare unless you're
hanging out at Gold's Gym it seems like
they're all around you but like in the
in real world those types of body types
you know they've kind of evolution
actually millions of years of evolution
kind of that they're a rare type because
they didn't survive very well in famines
you know they need too much energy for
to support all that muscle but anyway
most of us need that restaurant cover
when we workout this deeply there is a
natural recovery process that we
underestimate we think more is better we
think if you're not sore anymore we're
ready to go but that's because soreness
goes away it doesn't mean that the
building process of muscle has has ended
you still need more time think about
getting a cut your scrape you know it
doesn't heal overnight right I mean you
get a scrape it's not bleeding anymore
you know it is a scab on it but what if
you pick at that scab all the time it's
not gonna heal but if you leave it alone
even though it's not sore anymore all
right it might be a scab there it
doesn't hurt anymore it's not sensitive
doesn't itch you know but it's still
healing it's still gonna take a couple
weeks to heal well the biological
process of healing a scab or cut is very
similar to rebuilding a muscle after you
fatigue it very deeply so just because
the soreness goes away there's two three
four or five more steps that the body
goes through to build that muscle up and
you don't want to break down the muscle
before it's had a chance to build all
the way up and when we workout too much
we end up picking at that scab and we
never let the muscle gets reach its full
potential and we delay the process of
getting stronger so actually you know
again we look at the strength levels if
you're getting strong or working out
once a week week after week after week I
can keep ray
your weights and you keep getting
stronger why add more to it when once a
week is working fine you're getting
stronger we're measuring it is this
program extra effective for professional
athletes who have a long season and get
hurt like Karla getting hurt and like
their bodies are like hurt like well
like almost at the end of the season
stuff like that slowly it's surely the
athletic trainers of the professional
teams and college teams to find a
starting to recognize this you know keep
them safe
this risk management attitude and they
are slowly breaking out of that jock
mentality of just hitting the weight
room at all costs with all types of
methods slowly I think they would I
think athletes would benefit from less
wear and tear and a weight room because
they're already going through wear and
tear for their sport so I've always said
that you know again Ken Hutchins and
Arthur Jones they've you know I'm Way
before me have said the same thing that
you know you put an athlete in the
weight room you're turning them into
weight trainers not not the athlete that
they're supposed to be you know
so take basketball also if you're if a
baseball players in a weight room all
time you're turning them into a weight
lifter not a basketball player you got
to get these guys strong as safely as
possible and then let them play their
sport develop the skills to play their
sport you know that's the new paradigm
for for athletics athletes and
everything and slowly but surely they're
they're picking up on it but not fast
enough they're still so many athletes
overtraining and getting hurt they're
not they're not putting the pieces
together not realizing that one of the
reasons they're getting hurt so much is
because they're overtraining in the gym
and they're doing too much and not
allowing enough recovery it's too bad
you know I uh I didn't have a weight
problems I moved away I focused on
comedy and I strayed from the gym but I
always like lifting weights and I could
tell the difference and what I'm lifting
then and what I'm lifting now and I
could see the wasted movement the curl
for example you know 40% of his wasted
movement after a certain thing
you feel the muscle gets stimulated
you're giving the muscle time to breathe
and then you're going back up again with
with your system we don't specialize in
curls we have a pulldown hmm and at the
end the pulldown when you contract you
bet your ass you feel those biceps are
they gonna have a [ __ ] cable coming
out of them like Rocky Balboa no but the
strength is increasing what I found from
this program the most beneficial was for
me was a there was a plateau I had with
it or it started giving me anxiety and I
narrowed it down to my breathing the
breathing had to be just right when
especially on the squat I would go there
it started to become me going there
thinking to myself is just a damn pass
out of just want machine because the
anxiety is brutal to really do three
minutes of some max weight that last 30
seconds your heart's pumping you know
your booty or your thighs are on fire
that one muscle in your side of your leg
by your calf is on fire your feet but
you're focusing on your breathing I
suffer from sleep apnea and they did a
research a couple years ago that people
suffer from asleep at me the cancer
rates were going up because of lack of
oxygen sag asleep and lack of slack
asleep my lack sleep is a [ __ ]
I hope is very healing I don't tell you
that'll kill you more than oxycottons if
you ain't sleep since you I know for a
fact because I lived as a non sleeper
and now I live by some mice by somebody
who logs their sleep hours I log sleep
hours at the end of the month after take
a discount of my machine and send it to
a lab in fact they've gotten so ahead of
the game they send me an email
and the email tells you what nights you
slept dehydrated like last night I'm not
gonna lie nobody I got that seven days I
had a beer I saw guns and I'm sure that
will come out in that report that
because there was alcohol in my system I
was a little dehydrated
I drank ninety-two waters after that
beer and half a [ __ ] up margarita
wheel I have a half a larger
insurmountable at 20 weight watching
point slept over what's wrong with a
half margaery that's good for the soul
25 milligrams 25 that was life jack but
it's uh I really enjoyed your gym in New
York when you think of it and you know
if you're living in California or
Arizona or whatever
I really really advise you to stop by
and say hello to Adam or John or one of
the other trainers or the crazy blonde
at the front desk
hello I love to death and I'll tell you
why I was you know everything about New
York says insemination
and guess what I walked those streets
with a gun without a gun for 20 [ __ ]
years I walked from 20th to 88th Street
back I can't tell you how many people
I've seen mugged on the a train Express
and the regular one and still till this
day I'm intimidated when I walk into New
York you know how much courage that took
from me they have to call I just ask
mrs. G I said who's the cat who's the
[ __ ] in charge in New York of
doing this [ __ ] and she said the King of
Swing over on 51st Street but there's a
joint in Jersey but I would learn how to
take 18 rides down there and I didn't
like their web page their web page it
looks like you might fall asleep next
thing you know you're on Jeffery
Epstein's Island but they ain't doing
jumping jacks in front of a bunch of
their website instead of this clapping
for you I don't know it was a Chinese
guy
blur the eyes and I want to see the
eyeballs Annie why you teach this poor
old man how to do squat and your face is
blacked out it's like you look like
laughs bi surveillance photo is some
[ __ ] Oh like in Short Hills New Jersey
she told me to go see you I went up
there I took an uber as I went up the
stairs I [ __ ] my pants and when I walked
and I was home you had a little waiting
area you have wolf margarita bar
whatever the [ __ ] he got there selling
[ __ ] smoothies this [ __ ]
everybody was very you know you took my
guard away like I was expecting to go up
then you know what she was sit down some
he'll be with you in five minutes and
then some guy would come out with a
cigarette and though you're ready kids
when you go back there's 18 [ __ ] no
in fact it was it was like going to
acupuncture and lifting weights you know
all I needed was the Chinese flute in
the backseat to make me feel even warmer
and well thanks for saying that it was
don't we listen that's there's some fat
people in America and people who are out
of shape on America on that fat because
it's their choice it's heavy and set and
whatever I don't mean to insult anybody
it's to fear it's the fear it's the fear
if you've never gone to a pool and seen
a five hundred guy man with a t-shirt on
at the pool in the water you feel for
him if you have any type of compassion
but you also get angry at him because
you know there's help he's just a drug
addict in a different way just like I
was you know I look at my six-year-old
daughter I gotta chase it from time to
time what am I gonna do if I can't
[ __ ] chase her
so comedy let me tell you something my
friend I want to see Guns and Roses last
night they did a three-hour rehearsal
they're all over 50 right then in a
three hour rehearsal then they play for
three hours when I had Duff McKagan on
here Duff McKagan
let's go to kickboxing five days a week
with Benny Benny the jet whatever is
[ __ ] nameless when you saw him
running around that stage
you saw what it required if you don't
think the stones have somebody doing
jumping jacks with thumb and push up
signing jacks well at the edge at 70
you're mistaken when I did grudge match
with DeNiro he had his own personal
trainer and for DeNiro to be dinero he
has to work out five days a week for an
hour or calisthenics and pull-ups and
stuff like that so for me to do what I
want to do on stage and not have a heart
attack this is the best thing I could
ever do I like keep it going no I'm not
going anywhere this is this is part of
my routine I don't sweat going down
there no more I know that my legs are
gonna shake you know a little bit I know
that like I'll go up Thursday and then
get on a plane so I'll stretch really
well and then get on a plane at least
you know the only thing that people
don't understand about this program is
that when you put into your weight watch
your app you only get four points and
you know what the [ __ ] is this but in
reality you're ruining burning 10,000
points yeah or about that because a lot
of people don't know about exercising
it's like swimming
yeah but Swimming's burns the most
calories while you swim that's correct
word [ __ ] while you swim what happens
when you jump out of the water your
metabolism stops with your work method
of weight lifting I know my metabolism
is [ __ ] gone
anything that pushes you're used to the
max and when you're swimming slow and
steady you're not pushing yourself to
the max so it's about pushing yourself
to the max and that's what we're doing
we're taking your muscles so they have
nothing left and that that has very
profound effects when you do that now is
this with proper diet you see big weight
losses so far you guys yeah proper diet
is a key word what's best living in New
York I mean living in New York that's a
tough way to get a diet but New York
isn't the old New York you're getting
off with a lot of options now in New
York a lot of options if you don't want
to be a fat [ __ ] you know I would go up
to your neighborhood med war
you know even though my out I was on
36th Street I'd leave your place and
warm just sad to it no I'm not gonna lie
the animals gotta get a slice and then
if I didn't get a slice two doors down
there was a smoothie joint in the back
you got a PJ Clark's what was that
that's the hemp that's the famous
hamburger joint a block away no next
time that's not next time I go and head
down and three doors down there's a
smoothie place it's like a kitchen in
the front but when you walk into the
back check back they're making smoothies
and she'd give me protein with a little
pineapple coconut water very nice not
too much sugar from the [ __ ]
pineapple pineapples got
anti-inflammatory things that knockdown
so I would take care my son when I go
see you know Sam what do you have to
tell me anything you want to drop off me
and fun informed finished no I do want
to drop something with you though yeah B
what do you got I got you a gift you did
yeah you last you're talking you know
Ric Ocasek died you know yes you talked
about on your last show yes and you said
you loved that second album and I was at
amoeba and I got you there second you
[ __ ] beautiful I want to say anything
I heard it when I came in but I want to
say anything that I'm gonna give away
the surprise Ric Ocasek rest in peace
did you see him around the city no I
didn't seem around the city but you know
I was a big cars fan I remember you
joking around no one let you play cards
in their house or their car and like you
were like [ __ ] you that cars are great
been raped and they are great man I
loved him and it brings you know I hear
the cars it brings me back to my youth
and really good memories of summer camp
you know I grew up with Jewish parents
so they they send your wage summer camp
every year so like I have you know these
great memories of listening to the cars
and summer camp and and yeah this band
and when I heard he died I showed it to
your I mean I shouldn't see last Sunday
I was sitting watching football and
somebody sent me a message I was like
wow like it's crazy when our heroes die
you do like how can Ric Ocasek died
like you know how can what he did they
forget you know we really say we were
you know we were you and I am more or
less the same age I was yeah maybe when
it went down I'm a little bit younger
than you so I was like that was my last
year of summer camp you know right
before I stopped going to summer camp
and that was the album that was playing
what can they find your book at brother
anywhere power of 10
google it Amazon there anywhere you got
on the website also sure my website I
have a podcast if you want to hear more
about this and get into the weeds a
little bit about the exercise science
and all the stuff behind and here are
the interviews of some of these
incredible people out there that you
know I'm not I'm not the sole pioneer
with this I'm not the sole proselytize
there are a lot of people that are there
jumping on this bandwagon and
understanding what we're doing here and
you know quite honestly when you told me
your story I don't get sick of hearing
it the reason I got into this business
because of people like you that that
didn't know that you shouldn't be doing
anything else you know you need to do
this to stay strong and not get hurt and
there's a lot of people like that
it's not about sports then it's just
about getting strong and you know that's
what it's all about
no it's uh I think that you know I look
at the insurance in this country and you
just can't grow older anymore in this
country when you're in your toilet I
mean that there was a question I wanted
to ask you before we tape off huh
what are the differences between a
person who's 20 and the benefits of a
guy like me that walking toward you if
I'm a 25 year old guy that's never
touched the weight before what benefits
do I gain right off the top I know what
I gain is a 56 year old yeah my dick is
harder than Chinese arithmetic is I'm
saying that's a good question I'm sorry
to place it like the high no you have a
lot of people professionals will
listening but yeah a lot of guys my age
yourself with an erectile dysfunction
and it's important hey listen yeah I
just got [ __ ] hearing aids can I go
without my ears you can check them both
off in fact a can i while you rather
than take my fingers but let the [ __ ]
main thing I'm on this boy
all still worked at the end of time
saying and I think that adding that
blood to your legs and that you know I
know that bulky is when you walk into
your gym first and you do is to squat
you know to loosen everything up but it
really you release th ACH into your
stream which helps you burn down more
metabolism and stuff like that
there's a whole cascade of great things
that happen unbelievable if you workout
hard like what is the difference what
are the effects on the 25 year old to
say I'm a 56 year old piece of [ __ ] like
myself it's a good question me not I
just say to my I makes me think about I
wish I knew about this when I was 25
years old or even or younger I would
have gotten I would have gotten as
strong as I was back then but I wouldn't
I mean I had back surgery because of
working out the crazy doing deadlifts
and all kind of creates a high force
system and I've been basically suffering
with back pain ever since I was a
teenager and again you know a 25 year
old that that understand that you can
work out really hard and get strong as
[ __ ] and safely they don't have to work
they don't have to have to suffer with
the injuries out of us old farts are
dealing with now and that that's what
they can benefit from this there's no
workout that's going to do better for
them just because they're 25 years old
you got to work out hard you got a lot
they might have fast recovery ability
right so if you're 25 years old you heal
faster so maybe they can work out a
little bit more often but it's not like
they're doing this every day either even
if you're 25 you still can't sustain
this you know every single day so maybe
they can come twice a week you know and
and get the benefits from it but outside
of just maybe being able to do it a
little bit more often
the biggest gain that they get from this
is learning that they don't have to kill
themselves again it's a shape and they
can they can lead a pain-free life their
whole life and that's it that's a huge
thing I mean I've suffered with my back
over the years I've suffered
I mean spasms and bedridden and and and
and pain on a regular basis and it was
until I started doing the lower back
extensions and changing my diet doing
more of an anti-inflammatory - I really
I can't handle sugar at all around my
back starts hurting you know so between
an anti-inflammatory diet and working
out safely and not [ __ ] my back up in
the process while I work out you know I
would do anything to be bit 21 years old
again and and not do those dead lifts
like I did and do it this way instead
when are you still working on yourself
still you look great thank you
yeah of course once a week once twice a
week you know I have my little routine
that I do
John trains John John so damn busy they
were all so busy I can't get anyone to
train me they'll make me pay them I
really feel like they're like we're
expensive a time if you train you but
just you have to pay the session fee you
know free sessions man no there's no I
am really enjoy reading your book I'm
happy to open up my eyes and it reminded
me of this doll lifting it's been 15
months I feel great I'm stronger my
posture is insane after two shows a
night you know when you I used to go
back to the room and have to stretch out
my hips I don't have hip problems long
but the things they love yoke tight ever
since I've been doing the squats my
strength my strength on stage you know I
saw it I feel it when I'm on stage
sometimes I used to make a move on the
stage and I'd have to stop cuz I'm
getting anxiety attack the the squats
also helped me get off the
fight-or-flight what's that called
Firefly yeah fly the flight response
because first couple times it was like I
got to stop like that's it now to get up
and wrestling get dizzy and then you're
like what do I pay this money for not to
get dizzy I have to breathe this out
the breathing is so important the
breathing will get you an extra one or
two reps when you're [ __ ] by Jesus
Christ oh [ __ ]
you just keep breathing and you bring up
a good point is you're sending how the
first couple of times you throw it's
[ __ ] because you know you're finding
our range we're finding you well exactly
[ __ ] bait this is high-intensity
rebates this is safe exercise right this
is safe but it's hard so like you don't
just like take somebody off the street
the first time and kick their ass I mean
I've done that and I've lost them they
don't come back yeah we'll come back you
know but then again you take the risk of
saying listen we're gonna take it easy
the first couple times learn the
technique learn how to breathe right
then they walk out they don't feel
anything and they don't come back so you
have to kind of get their attention but
not too much you know because I don't
want to hurt them and discourage them so
there's this fine line between getting
them to feel wow that was cool that was
different I can see myself doing this
and not killing them the first time so
you probably they would they probably
took it easy on you the first time you
know yeah and you know you maybe they
could have pushed a little bit harder to
make you feel like you know but you
stuck it out and now you know now you
know I'm happy I'm happy that you guys
are running a great little stablishment
in New York I want their pretty business
for this and they have a parent or mom
because when Ken started this he started
this was a bunch of women yeah sources
projects University of Florida you did
your homework man yeah man
he started this to see the bone growth
uh yeah
older people that's what he started is
he just in the where the where they're a
bunch of old people who were weak
Florida and he started this thing and
that's where he saw the growth so if you
have a parent an uncle somebody who you
see is falling behind the wayside if
you're in a New York City area it's
never too late either no we have a
client in New York she's 95 dear Betty
there's a video of her on our website
she's 96 now how many days a week once
that's all she becomes I mean it's a
trek for her to get to us to I mean for
a 95 year old lady to come all across
town it's
it's work for her that's what she does
for the day she comes to us she works
out she goes home that's her activity
for the day
well I was really happy that you came on
time because I want to tell you about
your system I didn't tell this to the
church yeah I got the hearing aids this
week and it's good I'm gonna get an old
the pillbot a year ago I went for a
physical when he said that my heart was
a little weird then this right before I
went to see you guys I went for a
physical like a week before I met you
guys I finally went to see my heart
doctor and he had done a bunch of things
things I don't know why now
when I went to see you guys I had been
doing it it was April by 8 - this
program so I came back from seeing you
guys and then that's when they they did
the ink that's what it was they did the
ink [ __ ] no one left and I couldn't get
the results because many Saints have
called me in that quickly so for 3 weeks
when I went to see you guys I'm like
let's take a little easy just in case
and I was the leader I walked a lot and
the whole thing and when I came back the
guy goes listen I looked at your EKGs or
whatever he just miss saw a bump but
looking from my thing now your heart
hasn't got any worse you know they say
sleep apnea put a big strain on my heart
you know Halsey is and he knows it
doesn't look as bad as it did a couple
years ago I told him I know I've been
lifting and working out he went into
this whole thing about lifting over 40
and getting ready for your fifties his
gold he knows because that's the high
heart attack because if you make it to
60 if you don't you know he's a [ __ ]
wild guy this guy he goes if you don't
make it to 16 and you don't start doing
blue I don't start doing coke out of the
blue he doesn't be hit 60 or 70 he goes
my experiences is between the 50 and 60
marks oh [ __ ]
I could see that the results are in guys
so there you have it
Amen where's their address
to you 201 East 56th Street in Manhattan
nice we want to pull Washington Long
Island I said you tell the other one
Port Washington LA we got a couple in
Virginia at all trained by you certainly
one on California yep
where's the one in loving that one in
Sonoma real unfitness Anoa
Sonoma yeah Ronit Rohnert Park they
drink wine lift weights up to see oh
excuse me
well thank you very much ma'am the
website is informed fitness.com
that said it's that simple and not if
you're not available ask for the [ __ ]
the heir to the throne right there he is
he is he's the heir to the throne old
soul that Jonathan he's got a haircut
now he's ready he's ready he might be
like John Gotti might shoot you because
I'm a mistake it sparks he's your
biggest fan you know now I know he's my
brother Jeremy I appreciate you guys
coming on explaining your love and magic
Thank You Man what you do don't forget
[ __ ] you got five days to Chicago
will light the city on fire I spoke to
Josh Passini from 10th planet he's
picking me up even though I'm taking
care of my heart my heart could suck my
dick when I'm in Chicago cuz you always
gotta get a hot beef sandwich with the
sausage in the middle oh you ain't [ __ ]
and you gotta stop by the PO Box and get
a few pierogies too so I'll see you
savages Friday night Chicago two weeks
the Uptown Theater in Kansas City and
the following night on the 12th of
October they just add the show at the
Denver Paramount
it's a 9:30 show whatever do what you
need to do bring it on home real quick
before I take off I want to read you a
little word from my sponsor don't forget
tonight is Monday Night Football
you've been [ __ ] sitting there all
weekend with the thumb in your ass but
guess who's here my bookie [ __ ] let
me ask you something if you found the
yardstick on the street would you put it
back where you keep walking you're gonna
walk back a wall you're gonna walk past
a wallet
what type of [ __ ] [ __ ] are you
listen why are you keeping on picking
winners and not bet them that's why I go
to my bookie it
fast it's easy and they pay when you win
let's face it where you bet this just as
important as who you bet none so if
you're trying to bet on the NFL baseball
UFC Bellator whatever my bookies got it
I wouldn't be telling you guys to bet
with them if they weren't the best now
do the right thing if you're gonna bet
football this season bet with my bookie
the starters if you're the type of guy
that likes to bet a little and win a lot
try a parlay if all your picks come true
you multiply your winnings and no matter
how your bet the NFL season is the best
time of the year so do me a favor
cut the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] around
double your deposit today you
[ __ ] use promo code Church CH you
are CH and my book is gonna give you a
hundred percent bonus on your initial
deposit up to $1,000 who does that for
you they double your money just like
that even [ __ ] Ivan Boesky couldn't
do that type of [ __ ] visit my bookie
dalle g.com today that's my bookie grab
a pen cuz I know happy is a [ __ ] you
know my bo o ki e dot AG and don't
forget to use promo code Church when
creating your account to claim your
bonus listen with my bookie you play you
win you get paid it's that simple and
don't forget to check Instagram on
Thursday I'm dropping the uncle Joey
my bookie video pic of the week on mad
flavours world so I'll see you little
[ __ ] there and listen it's that
time of year everybody's looking to hire
someone everybody's got problems
everybody's got problems go to Dillon
muscle listen Dillon Miska which is a
real zip recruiter customer who use zip
recruit hire for his company Cafe Laura
the following is a testimonial script
based from the employer so do me a favor
go over and take a look read at that
hiring can be a slow process cafe tour
is CEO Dylan Moskowitz needed to hire a
director of quality
for his organic coffee company but he
was having trouble finding a qualified
candidate isn't that the story today
half of these guys are mutts
they don't know what they're doing but
you know what Dylan did he switch the
zip zip recruiter zip recruiter doesn't
depend on candidates to finding you it
finds them it's technology identifies
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job so you
get qualified candidates today Dylan
postman on his job recruit on the zip
recruiter and he said he was impressed
by how quickly had been given candidates
immediately he also used zip recruiters
candidate rating feature to filter the
applicants so he can focus on the most
relevant ones and that's how billon
found there's new director of coffee in
a few days with results like that it's
no wonder four out of five employees who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day so do me
a favor see why zip recruiter is
effective for businesses of all sizes
whether you got one guy or 22 people try
zip recruiter for free listen that's
free at zip recruiter comm slash Church
si-hu rc8 that zip recruit comm slash
shirts zip recruiter comm the smarter
way to hire I want to thank my bookie I
want to thank super cool
I also want to thank CBD line I gave my
man had him and Josh John Josh you know
me I'm a man I got in like 22 [ __ ]
joshan's in my life but it's Jonathan I
gave them both to CBD CBD bookie I gave
them both some CBD Lian calm heavy duty
on the milligrams I gave them the
tension that they don't get high this is
not a high this is for support go to CBD
lion calm and watch the lab results see
what each CBD treats if they got it
listen whether you smoke it shatter it
tincture it where you want the gummies
ain't nothing better than a raspberry
from CBD line calm go to CBD line calm
and press in church boom and get 20% off
your first order delivered the house no
more liquor stores no more [ __ ] hand
job parlor massages CBD line is the way
to go I want to thank CBD line my bookie
and zip recruiter I want to thank the
boys from inline Fitness in for informed
fitness I gotta stop smoking this
refresh I wanted inform fitness for
stopping and letting you know the beauty
and the magic they create know what I am
56 Street on the east side I want to
thank the [ __ ] but most
importantly I want that view
[ __ ] the supporting us and I'll
see you Friday
Chicago would take Quigley and my main
man beamed are is East a black where's
that Tony better that